على سعيد النا متصل نقلت رويترز عن مصادر
واديبلوماسيه قولها ان سفراء النيتو
سيعقدون اجتماعا تشوريا اليوم بناء على
طلب بولندا في حي انقله منسقوا سياسه
الخارجيه والامن في الاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيف بروريل انه يبحث عقد اجتماع ان
تنسيقي لقاده الاتحاد الاوروبي وذلك على
هامش قمه العشرين في بالي اندونيسيا هكذا
رئيس فلتانيا
بلاده الكامل مع بولندا مضيفا بانه علينا
الدفاع عن كل شبر من اراضيته اما وزير
الدفاع اسلوبك
ان تقدم توضيحات البشر ما حدث معتبرا انا
الافعال الروسيه غير المسؤوله تخرج عن
السيطره بحسب تعبيره فلا رئيس
بولندا الحالي في في الاتحاد
لا توتاس عن الحكومه المجريه ان رئيس
الوزراء فيكتور اوربان دعا لاجتماعي مجلس
الدفاع بشان اغلاق خطي دروجبا للنفط
والحادث في بولندا وزيره الخارجيه
الاستونيه ايفان ماريا لميتسو قالت بدورها
بانهم مستعدون للدفاع عن كل شبر من اراضي
النيته
وبانهم يعلنون التضامن الكامله مع بولندا
اما نظيرتها النرويجيه
فاعتبر في تصريحاتها لان سقوط صواريخ
روسيه في بولندا هي حادثه خطيره للغايه